quels souvenirs vous avez du lycée qui
est désordonné mais tvo imagine la
tombeuse du lycée celle qui était plus
grand plus forte et plus bruyante que
les autres ont rabaissé tout le monde
avec sa culture et son savoir mais on
m'a pas dit en balayant toute
personnelle où tu es parti sera rien
pourquoi tu veux le gâteau de joseph bat
enfin à nous il faut le rendre
c'est bien ou d'un quart d'heure on
restait un petit peu alors oui ce
n'était qu'un cauchemar justement je
faisais un bel 82 11 5e away en plus je
venais de du sud de toulouse et donc
j'ai un accent du sud à couper au
couteau et j'habitais paris
donc ce n'était qu'au complexe et je
voulais absolument me fondre dans la
masse et disparaître alors à quel âge
vous avez pris conscience que vous était
une belle femme eux
honnêtement bain une fois par mois son
gala à la naissance non mais bon on
n'est pas on est pas une
on n'est pas une belle femme on est une
belle femme que dans le regard de la
personne qui vous aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait adolescente très complexée en
fait mais c'était atroce avec 80 dans 5e
vous assure c'est compliqué à vivre
j'imagine ya truc plus compliqué à vie
mais ça s'est compliqué sur quelques
profs sol enneigé mais on va réhausser
louis moi j'étais un élève modèle mois
ah oui si je suis pas sûr j'ai même eu
le prix du sourire au cp parce que
j'étais toujours premier amour une map
rocks appeler mademoiselle a déjà 12 et
le tout venant et je souriais tout le
temps et il y avait tout le temps déjà
il y avait à l'époque fait des remises
des prix à la plume attend au prix de
lecture des prix on a été l'arrivée
devant un cas à présent les parents
recevaient des prix et moi je n'avais
jamais aucun prix à j'étais devant et je
rêvais d'avoir un prime pour briller
auprès de mazel tov d'eau qui du coup
mes parents sont allés la voir elle a
créé un prix spécial pour moi et qu'elle
ou prix du sourire j'ai pu briller chez
soi et sur la scène aux autres monnaies
m'a remis le prix du sourire je parie du
couillon en fait
maxime guinot bonsoir bonsoir c'est sûr
truculente commencer cette démarche
commencée avec un vieux mot là c'est
beau demander à rennes c'était la 4e
culot ryan
c'est beau hein c'est beau il disait
justement je me souviens d'un professeur
d'un formidable professeur de
philosophie et nous faisait un peu peur
mais il était brillant s'appelle
monsieur probable je le salue c'est
quand même fort monsieur pradal il va
s'il va se reconnaître et un jour on a
eu un inspecteur d'académie qui est venu
dans la classe on était tellement bon
avec les ping pong les questions
réponses que une fois que l'inspecteur
était parti il tony vous monter sur les
tables et on crie comme dans le cercle
des poètes disparus way
et puis bien sûr il a fait tellement
c'est gênant quand tu entends un blanc
partout et que la cpe est rentré en
panique puis que se passe-t-il
mais non il s'est bien passé et désolé
on est pas on dirait que j'espère ne pas
en direct et de toi que c'est une
histoire de ma vie qui donne t'on pas
piquée des hannetons et truculente
truculente je voulais la vérité oui h
est le plus beau le plus grand le plus
fort celui qui vient des airs et qui
finit par terre
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste que je me sens en verve et
habillé comme un écolier mathieu moi
mais c'est un écolier j'ai changé à la
peau j'aime pas en fait c'est trop là
j'aime beaucoup le mais c'est trop tard
non c'est pas vous n'êtes pas ségolène
et poix terron monsieur ça va très bien
la répartie aujourd'hui je te soupçonne
d'avoir une oreillette un casque alors
montchaude choisit pas son destin
tu as passé vilipendé j'avais vite on
choisit prime destin je ne dis rien je
fais très vite et sont donc à l'école
j'ai beaucoup de facilités
intellectuelles bon quoi mais j'étais
m'a donc j'étais très bon et j'étais à
l'époque chez n'est pas très grand et
pas très costaud et donc quand j'arrive
en sixième j'ai déjà fait je n'étais
jamais aimé à l'école d'homicide mais tu
sais c'est bête mais quand elle est
facilitée que tes plus beaux et plus
intelligents forcément ça agace et du
coup jamais ryan comment est-ce qu'on
supporte encore ses propos il avait 15
ans 6e but est bon c'est vrai je t'avais
du début mon père m'avait dit m'avait
dit ce qu'il faut c'est que ce soit
respectée donc le premier jour de la
rentrée sonne c'est victor duruy premier
jour de la rentrée tu arrives tu choisis
le plus costaud un peu crétin tu le
prends comme dans la cour et tu le
frappe et tu sera respecté toutes les
normes morales cas il va se battre à
l'école non non stupide mais c'était mon
père il est ce que tu puisses tu auras
mon rêve entre temps provoquer en duel
ce seuil mon père me dit tu appelleras
caïd donc jardin dans la cour
homme d'un coup jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
c'est le pardon à patrice pas ma force
je le pousse comme ça de la même manière
mais il bouscule un peu moi je pousse
une fois deux fois et se retourne pas
photo le plus gros il me faut deux bouts
paire de claques je tombe par terre à
samedi
je vais à l'infirmerie et toute l'année
on m'a n'ont pas appelé le caïd mrap
maps et le clown en classe l'année
merci papa il avait logé un défi vous
avez exactement 15 secondes où on nous
raconte réhaussé mort je me fasse
rentrer votre beauté l'année suivante il
émit toit plat parce que les patients
seraient mais ça m'a arrangé par rapport
à mon timing
bah oui alors fait la [ __ ] qu'il sera
prêt aux noms tels que nous faisions un
tour de table sur les arches dot a
priori rigolote qui l'école serait
arrivé à nos amis à l'école ou au lycée
pour l'instant c'est un fiasco total
mais peut-être que ça va rester un
fiasco avec isabelle oui forcément
alors je les raconte pour vous rien
parce que je pense que je l'aurais
dénoncé le maire de six ans non mais le
lybien elle-même peut pas le dire moi je
suis pour la gueule des raisons confuses
que j'ignore et est en sixième ont
considéré que j'avais une mauvaise
influence sur certaines élèves temps je
m'emmerdais personne je ne vais pas lui
demander à l'ennemi
on m'avait mise à côté de la meilleure
qui était supposée avoir une bonne
influence notamment en cours de maths et
donc c'est là que j'ai eu cette fameuse
injustice que j'ai déjà raconté ici mais
que vous vous connaissez pas 2 on a
donné un exercice de maths extrêmement
difficile donc j'étais persuadé que bah
j'avais évidemment pas savoir répondre
et tout le monde avec moi sauf que ce
journal est une fulgurance j'étais la
seule à savoir faire l'exercice est la
meilleure de la classe à côté j'ai très
vite compris que j'avais fait juste et
donc elle a copié sur moi et bien
évidemment c'est moi qui me 0 parce
qu'on n'a pas pensé un quart de seconde
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je sais que vous êtes toujours
pressés mais vous avez mis deux bouts
d'or est différente à chaque oreille oh
merde non c'est que j'ai perdu la vie et
celle ci est une de celles ci quitte à
les rentabiliser ce qui restait
lopez je les suis pas sûr de vouloir
passer après salon séjour supplie vous
êtes là pour réhausser le niveau alors
fait en sorte la réponse
grosse pression non en fait comme
j'étais en cinquième je faisais du volet
voilà j'adorais ça et en 5e j'ai
commencé à jouer au mini volley doit on
a des petits doigts très agile fin de ce
qu'on me dit de ce que me dit ma
compagne que de sexe c'est ça le gros je
te rappelle et chippendales quoi je joue
au volley est en fait celle à perdre
j'ai commencé à avoir des seins donc je
mets mon premier soutif ce que problème
c'est que c'était pas super pratique
pour jouer au volley donc je vais aux
toilettes j'enlève mon soutif et je le
met dans la poche de ma veste
vous avez joué sans sur ce motif oui
j'ai déjà très dangereux oui cordes
chinoise et de playtech compliqué bref
toujours est il que non il n'était pas
aussi gros à east erreurs au début j'en
suis à la poche de ma veste et je
commence à jouer et jouer à un pote qui
met ma veste au tour de son truc et je
le vois mettre la main dans les poches
et là je me dis la salle a pesé problème
est effectivement il a senti de spotify
de la cible il a fait le tour de la
coupe